to an impression right there oh yeah
from the first black widow trailer great
so listen it was like listening to the
music remember how long ago that was
my god guys it's greg and john here oh
what are we gonna watch today john we're
gonna watch the black widow new
trailer the new trailer they were like
we called it final before
yeah we're gonna call it new now well
yeah yeah
it's new blood it's like you know they
had the final chapter friday the 13th
followed the next year by new blood
right imagine that they finally decided
to cave put it on premier access and in
select theaters
i'm gonna be watching this in the
theaters i have a feeling it's because
there's going to be events in falcon and
winter soldier
involving thaddeus ross and considering
thaddeus ross is in here and to keep
what they have
going and the momentum of marvel back in
full motion
i'm like i think that's why they have to
release black widow yeah
yeah yeah they can't wait for things to
open yeah
absolutely they got timeline to uphold
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
before i was an avenger
[Music]
before i got this family
i made mistakes
[Applause]
vormir footage oh yeah
go dive into her past man
whoa where did you think i was all this
time
really going back to the beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he looks great
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dang
[Music]
there's your noise
[Laughter]
nice light motif
[Music]
this just took them like eight trailers
to get to the best trailer
i know that's right they've all been
great they've all been great
that was my favorite that's all it takes
declare something final and then
follow it up and no expectations yeah
right i feel like
what kind of took me by surprise out of
everything
was the the clear-cut reminder of like
this is a prequel and then
i felt like this trailer was really
going out of its way to say
this story must be watched this story
needs to be seen for the mcu like yes
she's already passed she's already dead
you've seen a lot of the legacy as
established in the avengers movie up to
her death on vormir
and then even the ending tune of this
trailer has a bit of that avengers theme
song in there with the theme
being made a lot of mistakes in her past
and she had to choose between what the
world wanted her to be versus who
who she really is i'm a sucker for
stories about
uncovering your trauma and having to let
your trauma go to become who you really
need to be and it seems like
thematically
that's what all this is really doing in
the backdrop of a
really cool espionage thriller you know
yeah
absolutely and i mean it's interesting
because there's so much action and
there's also so much history in this
trailer but i did
get like a like a family vibe like a
dysfunctional family vibe you know
obviously you have this connection
that's family vibe i'm a family guy
i'm a family but you know you have this
connection obviously between her and red
guardian
elena iron maiden and all them
all right john i can't keep interrupting
you oh strange i got a wedding to go to
two hours i gotta get all my taxes
together and then go to an appointment
we're both rushing and i am not making
it any better from what i understand
they're supposed to have sort of like uh
the russians-esque history and so then
having her go back in the present or at
least wherever the present is for this
movie i believe that's between civil and
infinity war
i feel like especially if they want to
pay homage to the
legacy of black widow and also set up a
continuation or pass the baton off
to florence pew it seems like they've
got a lot of really cool stakes going
because this trailer emphasizes the
conflict
between all these prominent people in
her life and her and her contentious
place
in the world and so it just seems like
there's going to be like a lot of
dramatic stuff to work past between
these main
characters here that probably will dig
back into their youth and yeah that was
the biggest surprise to me is like oh
damn i
didn't expect to see them as like little
kids you know potentially
having you have the red room history and
you know what that's probably going to
look like to some degree but
also from what i understand you have at
least elena and natasha as
young children for a while living with
red guardian and
uh iron maiden and so you know there's
got to be
rachel russian the sokovian name
molina molina there you go but yeah you
know you have
that which again seeing like i don't
think we've really seen any of the
avengers as actual children right so
like that struck me in this as something
that could be pretty interesting because
you think of her background and you
think oh yeah brainwashing and tactical
training
but you don't necessarily think of the
interrupt before you get a lot of crap
in the comments
um you see a baby vision in one division
that's that's the same thing the same
it's the same thing i just the exact
same
thing because that was a flashback to
actual history of
vicious challenges we are known for lame
jokes we are so
known for that and we gotta we gotta
tell you people want to make sure we go
in between serious commentary yeah yeah
i'm lame joke that's way too serious you
guys look like who's a baby avenger that
we once said
justice for baby vision all right blue
widow she's got blue hair
blue widow the whole family vibe looks
great i mean there looks like they're
really
i feel like they're all going to die in
here or they're going to picture if
they're going to die or they're going to
betray her in some ways
supposed to be in hawkeye if i'm not
gonna say i think there was already uh
photos of that
yeah and they're setting up some kind of
baton pass and i don't think we saw
thaddeus ross in here but we did see
some ray winstone
and that's something that took me by
surprise i thought taskmaster would be
the one who's like
just doing everything on his own and
then in this trailer
whoever ray winstone is playing and if
you guys know please
let us know whoever ray winston's play
looks like he's
kind of controlling him yeah and i
thought taskmaster would be his own
personality and be his own
boss basically looks like he's working
directly for whoever ray winston he's
like
go get go get them [ __ ]
[Laughter]
get them to my
that's the perfect it's like he's right
here in the room you know right
what i want a lot of people realize
right that's for the deep down sound
yeah
and it makes me wonder though seeing him
with taskmaster if there
might be some kind of subversion there
because you have you know black widow
and company squaring off against
taskmaster who all
like the black widows all have
experience with handlers and people
controlling your actions and stuff while
taskmaster has a rich history as just
being a villain uh you know you never
know
there could be something more to that i
feel like now more than ever they're
willing to kind of tweak the history to
throw you off yeah i mean i just don't
want it to be
where he's just a muscle yeah i want him
to be a real character
yeah and so far like this was the one
trailer
like this is some of the best taskmaster
it's weird how
it has both the best taskmaster preview
footage we've yet to see
especially in those final moments looks
absolutely incredible yet
it also got me a tad concern that he's
just going to be a muscle
yeah you don't want him to be like a
less expensive terminator soldier
yeah yeah i just don't want it to be
another terminator yeah um he's got to
be unique
so yeah the music in here is great this
is all going to be awesome i wanted to
play as young
young natasha i wonder who plays her
anyway guys what do you think of black
widow final trailer are you going to
watch it on disney plus
are you going to watch in the theaters
leave your thoughts down below hey do us
a favor jon
close this out make it snappy guys
remember to like subscribe hit that
notification bell get updated the next
time uh
mr white the next time a black widow
trailer the final final final trailer
drops
thank you to all of you all who joined
us on patreon
and uh you got a wedding and i got taxes
we'll see you later
we gotta do patreon we gotta do a
patreon day
mikhail linden you're not russian or
sokovian but you do live in
sweden and uh i've seen your picture on
this patreon here and i feel like you
would be a perfect casting choice to be
like the handler
of some kind of international assassin
you got the glasses you look a little
bit unassuming but i have a feeling that
when mikhail wants to get into
if mikhail was about to slap me around i
would be terrified i would be like
wrapped with attention i would be like
look whatever you want mikhail don't
hurt me just tell me what you need me to
do i will be your task master mikhail
i love you buddy the better shout out is
better than what i would have done
thanks for being here thank you